question who do you think who do you
think cheats more men or women and do
they oh she's going to hit us with
statistics
who do you think cheats more men or
women and do they cheat differently i
think we cheat differently i think men
cheat more okay but we definitely cheat
differently yeah like i feel like and i
know it's gonna sound bad but when women
cheat is worse yeah i was gonna say that
i i knew you guys would say that their
argument is because when the girl cheats
because she has feelings for him he's
but that's usually what it is it's about
like it's about emotion it's about on
top of that like as a girl when a guy
sleeps of a girl he just sleeps over you
can you can just like you can literally
sleep with her even worse
that's not worse
like if you were to cheat would you
cheat with someone ugly than your
boyfriend
no
there we go oh wait it depends
the first thing you see is someone's
attractiveness obviously but i think if
someone's
not better looking than your boyfriend
necessarily but he provides you with
something else emotionally you get more
attracted to the same point you're going
to say that's worse right than you're
cheating with someone that's the point
they're making is the guy has something
your boyfriend doesn't doesn't okay
where a girl like like okay i always say
this like do you remember the day you
realized you had to worry about ugly
[ __ ] too
[Laughter]
you said it
look it like i was like you thought her
but it's because like guys it's more of
like an instinct they're like oh god
boop like
boobs bump like ass
i don't even like see what she looks
like
i don't even notice she was fat like
like that's what i'm saying like guys
it's more of just like an immediate
response where girls like we have to
connect with them on some level we have
some prerequisite for them sleeping with
us
it takes a while for a girl i think men
like have you ever have any of you ever
slept with a girl that you would never
want to be seen in public with yesterday
no no no no i said that as a joke back
me
how good are my standards they're
impeccable impeccable all my girls are
top three they're always top three
they're always set free
on my heart i'll put it there
everyone has their person that you would
the world can never know about but
television has always been
has always been champions league level i
told you on top
[Music]
okay what about you guys
haven't to be fair i'm like my man i've
got it
i know like i was saying earlier like
there are guys that are dogs that they
will just sleep with anything just
just because they can or try and get
their numbers up or at uel
[Laughter]
wait put that put that on the floor
romeo turn off the camera
no don't be shy go ahead let's go ahead
yeah there's guys obviously they'll
they'll just sleep with girls at uni
just because they know or they know
she's easy like they're bored or they're
like horny or whatever they'll just
sleep with her
but yeah like girls aren't going to do
that
or less likely to anyways
do i think for guys like
that behavior usually
i'll say okay there are two types of
guys the guys that have like could get
girls from
a young enough age and they're really
really super late bloomers so i feel
like you always go for a phase where
it's like you're just you don't
just go for it
and then usually that that that phase
usually ends like after uni whatever and
then you're just in life and you and you
you can turn down sex
whereas those guys
who are super late bloomers are the ones
that like in their mid-20s and they're
just like they will literally go
anywhere and do anything and it's just
like it's the ones that got like they
had no girls at school and suddenly like
they're attractive now they start
hitting gym or whatever they can
suddenly get loads of girls and then
they just like don't know how to like
control it like when i was composure
i said one thing i was like how do you
expect to play champions league games if
you don't play preseason
ah so you gotta build your levels up you
gotta listen
are you okay wait can i can i clarify
let me just understand so crazy so you
gotta sleep with the uglier girls to get
to the hotter girls not to get to go but
if you're not on form
okay so like so like so you guys are
practicing i can't relate
so the ugly girls are like practice
not not me that's like it's like a
friend
it's like
someone else would be bad
i would never
am i wrong no okay when i was like a
younger like
it's all coming out now
no but yeah yeah that's that's
like trying to not upset the ugly girls
[Laughter]
okay um
so okay do you guys think that um
because we were kind of talking about
how cheating is different for men and
for women right
um and i want to tie this back into
social media okay
do you think that it's cheating if a
girl's posting
ass pictures on the internet in a
relationship 100
that's cheating yeah
i wouldn't say cheating cheating is like
a strong word i would say that yeah
i feel like it's disrespectful or like
yes she's overstepped her boundary i
wouldn't say like
she's cheating i think if that issue
your air sorry no you show your ass on
the beach you know and then
what's the problem that's the thing i
know it's a very thick line
about sharing it on instagram it's
calling for attention but then you are
again you are proud of your body you
want to show it if you are over showing
okay that that recalls like for
attention like you're over posting about
your ass about your boobs about your
body all the time i get it but if you're
sharing like a bikini or a lingerie
photos just you know once in a while
what's the problem with that you're like
you're proud
i think i think it's just i think but i
think it just screams easy to me
to me it's like girls they aren't easy
in real life
if there's a thing where you like do gym
and stuff and like your personal
training like obviously you work for
your bum and that's fair enough in it
because that's part of your brand your
business if you're just any normal girl
and you're posting a picture of your
nash
then listen yes
like why are you posting a picture of
your of your behind like that's
disrespectful
that's an open invitation for hella dms
no but like i feel like
girls often times
sexual attention with like relationship
attention because like they'll put this
ass picture on the internet one that's
going to be there forever like your kids
like are going to see that someday is
that the thing what if
a guy posts like a topless pic or
something
when he's in a relationship if a guy
does it if a guy does it i mean okay
it's twofold right one yeah i don't
think i i do think it is
i do think it's kind of douchey to be
honest
um but honestly i think it's a double
standard yes i think it's more cheating
for women than it is for men because
most men aren't going to get girls in
their like dms like that and i think if
you're a guy and you're posting a
topless picture there's one or two
things i have a hench because you've
actually worked for it
so it's just like fair enough like you
might be a bodybuilder whatever the hell
or you're like hella tired and it's just
like it's art not art but do you know
what i mean you're trying to show your
tattoos yeah but you still want to
you're still on attention like you guys
okay it's not the same because girls
don't really
see like a chest and are like i want to
have sex with that like
like guys guys see an ass and like
the
you know it's it's wait so so
you place on it you might get like 20 30
replies i don't know how many i posted
like a chesapeake you might get a one or
two if that
can i mean
that down to the fact that we're we're
always the ones pursuing whatever
whatever you do will lead to more than
what if we do something because girls
aren't going to make that first move
yeah because guys usually are moving to
girls rather than girls move into guys
yeah we're we're the sales people yeah
we are
low of averages you gotta move to anyway
let me know
but i think like uh women are seen as
more as a sexual um
than men that's why in general let's
start there but if i see like a male a
as a model like a really nice model and
i see and i like his body you can
actually get turned like in a way like
wow sexy yeah i would do him why not
like no but
like
he crosses your mind sometimes he does
it's not just like as a you know okay
okay but it crosses your mind sometimes
it does right but that's that's of
course they see boobs and and above
they're like ah you know oh my god i'll
go there i would dive in i mean like
guys have a thing such as like a sex
doll
that's the thing that men purchase six
dollars a six dollars yeah yeah like a
girl would never buy that yeah
like yeah but you don't buy your little
toys and stuff
but yeah yeah girls have way more you
live with me you know i don't have one
no but i'm saying like men are more
attracted to like a body like that's
what i'm saying like like why do they
need that visual because like men are
more attracted to like
like they're more visual than women yeah
sure
i mean
who's gone for a guy that's ugly but
funny
no oh just
i have
i have yeah yeah that's because women
fall in love with what they hear men
fall in love with what they see yeah
that's why i feel like it's a double
standard and it's different for men and
for women
[Laughter]
okay so um
do you think in a marriage it would be
better if both partners just deleted
social media if you really want to be
married for a long time i was going to
say i think like it would cause less
stress like maybe not instagram because
you can use that for business or twitter
but like snapchat like why would you
need like your friends can text you you
don't need stuff like that
when you're in relationships why you
have snapchat yeah if you have snapchat
you are in the streets sorry
if you have snapchats
me i deleted it because
nothing good comes from snapchat i
re-downloaded it
i mean i just got it
you know i mean
designed for secrecy like what good can
oh my god i need to tell you once
you know you can download the data from
a snapchat and get every single message
that someone has sent or received ah how
how
don't ask me don't ask me don't ask me
how i know how do
wait can i just see my own messages or
troy's messages both if you well if you
know his passcode for no reason
wow
yeah like i i did it
i mean i never um did that
oh no no but you know it what no i saw
it on tick-tock
i was like oh cool did it actually work
[Laughter]
anyways i'm single now
um no but
yeah
i agree snapchat i think in general is
kind of
just
deleting social media just give
just make it easier so you're not
tempted or
there's no
jealousy things like that i mean you can
keep facebook nothing bad happens on
facebook it's just a bunch of like one
who still used to be surprised
yeah you'd be
and one of the number one like um there
was a divorce lawyer that talked about
um one of like way that couples get
divorced after like 20 30 years is
because they get a friend request from
like a high school ex
and then they they leave the
relationship for it and then they
remember all the reasons they broke up
20 years ago yeah with the x
and then they they both end up single
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think social media is just
i i don't know like
maybe some social medias don't really
what's that's on twitter i'm not sure if
you know but
i think twitter is like a social media
site where
nothing that bad happens like who moves
to people on twitter i feel like if you
take away one then it'll just
it'll just transfer to it social media
platforms they're all copying each other
like even twitter has stories like they
all like they're all basically the same
like when something goes well like the
tick tock scrolling thing they have that
on snapchat on instagram like they all
just start copying each other that was
popping well and the other thing is i
think social media has raised women's
standards a lot because like they'll get
messages from guys that they would never
get approached by in real life not even
i was gonna say he was talking about it
earlier but girls can lich it's insane
you see these people on tv and they're
big you get you can literally just dm
them and they will dm you back
like does that happen to you
nba yes or no any nba players yeah i'll
say yesterday okay nfl
no no
what about an actor any famous actors
yes really just not messing with you oh
show me i won't i won't say i'll show
you i'll show you i see
i i won't
let me yes
i won't say i won't say the name i
wouldn't do that i would please don't i
won do you like that
okay okay okay all right
wait
[Music]
wait wait
omg what the
he dmu um
or did i it's 2019. i think isolated oh
okay and we followed each other for a
while oh wow okay
they won't see they won't see um
that's
that's crazy but that's um the point is
it's very everything happens on social
media like it's so
easy nowadays you see these people and
you're like oh i could never get in
touch with them
and then suddenly you're in touch with
them so do you take that because okay
i've um
i did an experiment actually where for a
video where i dm'd 50 um nba players to
just see if any would respond okay and
you guys can watch it on my channel go
help me get my watch time up um please
there was like two or three that
responded but it's interesting because
to me i'm like
i would never consider that to be like
real because like i know he's just
trying to sleep with me
like i like you're not but you should
talk about a reply for him didn't you
think that's insane yeah but i just
i don't know like to me it doesn't
really mean anything because i feel like
those guys just do that do that with
with to everyone like you just have to
be half good looking and they'll
whatever but it's not like they want
anything from you they just i mean what
are your odds of locking down an nba
player good luck
even the why even the girlfriends like
you have to share them basically
actually you know what i mean
yeah but this is just um
sorry
i was gonna say again oh [ __ ] it's just
left me
yeah
that's okay
no oh no it was on your point actually
yeah so yeah and this is why i think
that cheating
is worse than what's easier for women to
cheat than it is for men yeah on social
media that is because
you said like these high-profile people
would reply to both of you yeah but if
any of us were to
like these verified instagram models the
chances of them replying to us purely
because we don't have a
a blue tick
on social media is
basically zero agreed
do you think that cheating is different
for men and for women
like do you think do you because there's
some people in the manosphere that think
that
if a guy cheats you should try to work
it out because it could have just meant
nothing to him
but if a girl cheats it's the
relationship is over but that's what
we're talking about though for me if a
guy cheats on me it's over there is no
way
to come back this is gonna sound really
wild though yeah but like when a guy
cheats
the girl is never better looking than
his girlfriend and this is the point i
was gonna make before
because the guy doesn't wanna the guy
doesn't actually wanna it's gonna sound
so mad the guy doesn't actually want to
leave his girlfriend he doesn't want to
fall in love with another girl he act in
a weird way
most i'm
not those toxic on what is toxic but not
those like weird ones but like um the
abusive ones but like in a weird way
the guy still loves his girlfriend
and in the back of his mind he doesn't
actually want to leave her or fall in
love with someone else so the girl he
cheats on is usually never as good as
his actual girlfriend if that makes
sense
yeah go because girls would be more
likely to
now if you was a guy you would end the
relationship and then get with the girl
you wouldn't but we don't if you if she
was if she was better but we don't end
relationships yeah guys
guys settle
and and that's the worst thing i feel
like girls when they cheat tell me if
i'm wrong but they do it in such a
twisted way like i thought i know so
many girls that will like sleep with
guys friends after they like broke up or
if they're seeing each other in a little
break you know what i mean guys don't do
that [ __ ] because it's just like bro i'm
not gonna sleep with your broker
brokered this one
if you cheat on your girl you're never
gonna bring that girl in the same room
as the girl you cheated with a girl who
literally walks you in makes you spud
this guy chill play fifa
and
i just had to say one thing you said bro
and that could happen both ways
a guy's not going to risk it because
they're risky
girls yeah yeah yeah yeah that's true
that's true
very
true i've done that but
no if a guy if a guy slides in my dms
and i see on his profile he has a
girlfriend just send it to her
oh as you should
snitch we should sleep
we should start snitching but you guys
don't stitch because you don't care
no no no we just we just don't snitch
it's like it's just like because if a
nice girl slides your dm but then she's
got a guy
if you snitch and it's going to mess it
up so you just be like just chill until
she doesn't have a guy and then
come back
but broco doesn't exist anymore it's
disgusting no it doesn't no it doesn't
it does something
it does it's just not there
yes
with all women whereas guy code is like
it's with yours yeah
you're in a relationship with a girl you
end it and then she's trying to move to
you
even if you find a mad attractive you're
not gonna be like you still haven't
you're going to tell your boy that now
but then if
it's a random guy you don't know then
there's no bro
he's saying if it's like your homie
uh-huh they wouldn't i promise you that
i wouldn't oh my god some experience
like they will
oh my god no they'll be
[Music]
their friends will flirt with you too in
front of the guy i swear to god
i'm about to just
thank you point that's happening
that's not women don't know about it's
either sometimes it's not your boy but
the majority of the time it's because
that guy has pressed triangle and given
the through ball and you don't even know
he's literally one chest pass
you haven't seen it no look past and in
the guys that you've given his blessing
yeah yeah for the other guy to literally
make his move so sometimes i've got like
a goal be like oh my god your boy is
doing this and
is it
i know inaudible
it's it's mad as well guys guys
yesterday guys guys will ask guys who
asked me like oh bro is it a cool if i
yeah if you say yeah yeah the girl fakes
are like you i got with your boy and
he's not even telling you like not like
you're the one that assisted your bro
yeah you said you gave him the green
light he's like yeah yeah
right good do your face good
okay i will say with cheating okay if a
guy cheats on me
now
i'm gonna leave right and the reason
being is because
i feel like
like we're not even married yet like
okay if you're doing it now like the
future can't be bright right but i think
if you have a child it's not about you
anymore
so if i had a kid with someone i would
try to work it out yeah because i think
like like your feelings are kind of
irrelevant when you have a kid and i
would never want to put a kid at a st
like at every like that's
how do you put it sorry um at a
disadvantage for their life and like a
kid is at every statistical disadvantage
if they don't have both parents in the
home like they're more like 80 of people
in prison we're born from a single
parent home
um
about i mean i'm a nanny i work as a
nanny for 10 years and i've seen
um a lot of kind of different families
single mothers both parents
and i came from i mean my mom is single
and she raised me i i had no father
present in my life and
that was good i think because he cheated
on my he my father cheated on my mom so
and she needed she never wanted to work
out and i think that's best because if
you don't trust the person then in the
back of your head you're gonna always
have trust issues and then those trust
issues that will
um you know lead in your head
like to travel like
in the house and
for this child like to see the parents
like fighting all the time for little
things because they don't trust each
other well but that's why that's how you
like go to therapy and like find other
ways to work it out and afford
i mean therapy yeah i just everyone can
have that
luxury you know to have therapy or to
have people around them and to support
them because we are you know
we're not all coming from the same place
right yeah but like even
like before the invention of like birth
control like honestly people stayed
together through thick and thin
people didn't just leave like like there
were so many times where the grandpa had
like a family on the other side of town
nobody knew about
yeah before instagram right because now
these days
you know they always see and a better
option they go so you know don't work on
they don't and it's not i just i just
think like at the end of the day it's
not about you and you have children like
like like why would you want to put your
kid at that disadvantage
i know getting cheated on is terrible
like that's a whole like that is the
worst feeling in the world like you feel
like absolute [ __ ] but like at the end
of the day if i had kids like it's not
about me it's not about my feelings
it's about the kids go ahead so if your
your partner cheated on you when you had
kids you would stay with them mm-hmm
but how many times let's say cheated on
you 10 times and you caught him i do
that has to be like a limit there is
there's i think it's like if um
if he gave me something
i think i would leave yeah like like an
std or something or like
if um
it became like public you know i mean
like he was doing it so much like
everyone knows you know um
i don't know i'd have to think more
about it there is a line but i'm saying
if it's like a one-time thing
like i don't know men and women are
different and you you would stay with
them
and work out if i had kids i would try
to work it out
i would give him probably a chance yeah
i think everyone does mistakes and
nobody's perfect
but
more than once no i would cheated on him
on purpose then my idea actually wait
wait
i give you an apple okay that's it with
me but what happened here no no no well
you realize that that lowers your value
like you're you're kind of playing
yourself because like you're just saying
oh i'm for the strength
as well like forgiving so many times
this guy who cheated on you all the time
so just because you have a kid i mean i
don't want my kids to be raised by a guy
that is a cheater because even just
being but then then he'll be raised by
two cheaters
[Laughter]
yeah i was speaking on your behalf okay
okay no no no no go ahead go ahead i
would never accept a cheater to come
back to my life okay
never you know never you've never done
that no i've never been cheated not that
i know i mean um so yeah
and let's pray for him if he cheated on
me and i know i'll go back to my ex and
then probably i will cheat around him
but i don't have no kids i can do it
no i'm joking okay anyway
don't keep talking keep talking
okay okay so
the relationship we have a kid and he
cheated on me
okay i would forgive him once but twice
huh you're dumb
i just
my kids to follow those steps well i
know but
you're giving him more of an example to
follow
the first time
if i was you okay yeah first time
okay family let's let's have a happy
family second time oh
i will show you how to cheat then
i will invite him i actually imagined
these in my head you know
better let her go i will call him hey
baby let's go to the hotel
you know five stars
not not two stars i know motel okay i
bring the handcuffs you know oh handcuff
okay i'm like yeah let's play kinky
right okay
the best looking guy i find you know and
then i [ __ ] him in front of my husband
whatever it is wait but we'd say you
would you wouldn't
you would okay okay let me let me just
let me just let me just get this
straight let me oh he feels what i felt
not just once but twice uh
darling okay let me let me let me just
unders i don't know one i feel like the
guy would probably leave oh that's good
okay
second second
second second second you realize like
okay
this is what we mean by girls cheat
worse
[Music]
bringing us back to the beginning
you see what i mean
i never cheat on no-one
oh
handle [ __ ] don't start the game that's
it okay okay but how does that help you
a lot
no how does that that guy the ego is
gonna be more little than his penis
[Laughter]
in the whole world okay
okay okay